okay so out of the Dragon episode 8 is
now out and the brand new entry is
currently upping the ante like Jon Snow
in season seven it's a big family affair
with a side's metaphorically Burning
Down The House
there's a lot to impact from this one
and throughout the video we're going to
be recapping the plot pointing out all
the Easter eggs and talking about how it
differs from the book Fire and Blood now
the entry combines several years from
the timeline in order to tell its Story
the two major events in it are the death
of Raymond which is later followed by
King viserys who sadly passes away at
the end of the entry in the books the
first of these happened in 126 AC with a
ladder happening three years later in
129 therefore they've kindly combined
several events into this hour-long
episode and according to the creative
team this will be the last time jump in
the series from here on out we'll be
traveling into the dance of the Dragons
which is described as being the far more
elegant name for the Civil War amongst
the targaryens this was foreshadowed all
the way back in episode 1 with this line
from an elderly rhaenyra the only thing
that could tear down the house of the
Dragon
was itself the episode is titled lord of
the tides which is a title traditionally
held by the house of valerian the people
who gain this instantly get the island
of driftmark along with the naval powers
of Blackwater Bay this also typically
makes them the master of ships on the
council and it's a heavily sought after
position most of this episode centers
around one single paragraph in the book
that talks about Raymond claiming to be
lord of the tides and then getting
beheaded before he's fed to Cyrax we
open the episode with a shot behind the
throne teasing out who's sitting in it
over the top of this we can hear renise
asking about the state of her husband
who has been mortally wounded in battle
this is a changer from the books as in
that it describes him as just being
struck with a sudden fever this happens
after the battle but there's no mention
of any fighting happening in the source
material the work describes how he was
surrounded by maesters and due to his
ill health the question of succession
came into play now though I've mentioned
129 acli but I think this is more likely
taking place in 126 due this line by
renise it's been
it spins out as 120 AC and therefore the
68 Gap could be telling us that it's
126. at this point Raymond ends up
stepping forward in order to try and
seize the position of the air this is of
course meant to Mira Damon the brother
of viserys who too sought to become the
ruler until this was stripped from his
hands even the name Damon and Raymond
sound similar but were as d-dog was told
to head off Raymond is told to head off
now he talks about how Corliss only
cares about the history books and this
mirrors the scene from last week in
which he talked about her names were
more important than blood this ambition
is what drives him and he ends up losing
out in the Game of Thrones due to trying
to oust the strongs buserous has been
appointed as the heir of driftmark and
though you might automatically think
that it would pass to jiserus he's the
one who's inheriting the title of the
Iron Throne we've seen something similar
recently after the passing of Queen
Elizabeth and her son Charles ended up
becoming the king his title of Prince of
Wales was then taken away and given to
his son Prince William it's a similar
situation in Westeros where you can only
really have one title at once and this
is why it goes to Luke instead of his
brother Jace after he mentions the
strongs Renee says this line my cousin
the king would have
something like this happened in the
books and after Raymond was killed his
cousins went to viserys to try and
demand Justice in Hell before him
detailing how his grandchildren were
strongs and viz sat there in silence
waiting for them to finish once they did
he ordered for their tongues to be cut
out because viz in the box is a complete
Savage I have talked about this a lot in
past breakdowns and though there's
teases towards him wanting to do this
they could do the chase with one of the
biggest shock moments in Game of Thrones
history you've also already had a
similar scene with Laris basically doing
the same thing with his assassin and
therefore I can see why they skipped
over it rhenice being the one on the
throne also somewhat mirrors the fact
that baymen says Alison is actually the
one who sits on the Iron Throne these
days we'll get into this more in just a
bit but the killing of Lionel strong has
allowed her to take control of almost
everything with her father being the Han
and she being the Queen the Burke talks
about how viserys's interest in being
near the throne stood to disappear as
the BS started Mound up man just wanted
to finish building the title sequence on
his train set and thus it says he rarely
attended court it's also important to
bear in mind that the book describes him
as being very short of breath during
this time and thus he was often carried
through the Kingdom on one of his Royal
chairs in the book he didn't lose his
fingers until after the thing with
baymund and it's said that after this
that he never sat on the throne again
though he returns to the throne room in
this entry he's a shell of his former
self looking like Gus fraying after
their bell rings and I think the eye
missing is symbolic for a number of
reasons Eamonn of course lost his and
viserys refused to act on it which
caused Alison to hate that side of the
family even more in the end he rocks a
mask that looks like the same thing crab
feeder had on and this was actually a
repurposed one from the sons of the
harpy The Mask wasn't present in the
book and we'll talk about how his death
is described in that as it differs
slightly from what happens with Gollum
now I tweeted earlier in the week that
if you bought the funk over him you had
to keep putting in the microwave after
every episode to keep it up to date
however even with that in mind I was
completely shocked with how bad he looks
now this video is sponsored by a step
published titles a gift that lets you
become like your favorite Lord a lady in
House of the Dragon did you know there's
a traditional Scottish custom to have
landowners referred to as a lord lady or
a lad that's why I was super interested
in this project which allows you to get
at least one square foot of dedicated
land in Edelson Scotland it's also a
great way to help out the environment as
established titles will plant one tree
with every single order they work with
Charities like one tree planet and trees
for the future to help with
reforestation efforts so if you pick up
a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst helping to preserve the
picturesque Woodlands of Scotland now
there also comes a bit of an ego boost
on top of all this environmental stuff
because you're now a lord ladder a lady
you can officially change your name on
things like credit cards plane tickets
your dating profile whatever you want to
do as you can see here they give you an
official certificate and it also details
the exact location of your unique plot
number on top of this established titles
have also told me that the first 200
people who use my link below will be
placed Within walking distance from my
plot depending on how many of you want
to become a lord lady a LED we can build
our unique heavy spoilerm Kingdom
together you can be like Lord Kevin
spoilers you punk I'll see you jump
established titles is actually running a
massive early Black Friday sale right
now plus if you use the code heavy
spoilers you get an additional 10 off go
to establishtitles.com heavy spoilers to
get your gift and help support the
channel makes for a great last minute
gift you can get yourself involved in
all the house of the Dragons drama so
definitely go check it out in the
description below thanks anyway after
driftmark we cut to Dragonstone which
has several parts of its castle that
look like the jaws of a Dragon Smoke
surrounds the cave and we catch Damon as
part of the billionaires belonging crowd
looking at cyrax's eggs last week they
lost his ex-wife's dragon vegar and now
they're desperate to get something to
help even the playing field these
clutches of eggs are described in the
book as being laid in 118 AC which is
the same year in which raniera betrothed
her two strongest boys to Elena and
Baylor didn't mean anything by calling
them strong boys hair this happens in
the episode but it's more of a play to
keep the kingdom as her sons rather than
doing it for the sake of doing it like
it's in the book The episode also
introduces the two kids that Damon and
rira have together in egg on the young
Gap and also viserys Nera also appears
to be pregnant in this entry hinting at
the next one coming along the way who
I'll talk more about in the spoiler
section the slow decline of renira in
the books is also a big thing that the
show is kind of glossed over and they
may start to delve into this more in the
following episodes in the opening of the
chapter she's described as being the
realm's Delight however as this story
goes on it says she gets ugly or I'm fat
at due to a number of reasons the first
is that she has five kids in a couple of
years but beyond that there's also the
constant stress that being the air
brings though Allison is often depicted
as the bad guy it also has moments of
talk about haranira grew better over her
because she retained her figure and the
text also brings up how Alison took the
baby being called aegon as a slight to
hear and even though raniera denied this
as she did do it on purpose it says in
King's Landing however Queen Alison grew
most wrath when she learned the Babe had
been named aegon taking that for a
slight against her own son aegon which
according to the testimony of mushroom
it most certainly was egg on the
concrete is of course a major person in
Targaryen lineage who took them to the
point that they ruled six of the Seven
Kingdoms his name being brought forward
was very important with them even
getting to the point now that they're
fighting over who should carry it Baylor
sends a message to her father about what
Raymond is trying to do and we could to
an Era who goes to her recast Sons we
see jacaris practicing his high valarian
in front of a great table which is the
same one that popped up in Game of
Thrones is also Geoffrey in the
background who looks about six-ish again
supporting this being 126 ac they decide
to go to King's Landing which we can see
still has scaffolding on it due to it
being under construction this was shown
in episode 1 and obviously they won a
show it's being worked on with his being
a prequel series they're greeted by Lord
Caswell who you might remember as being
the person on the stairs when raniera
had to bring Joffrey up he's one of the
only loyal supporters left during era
and this actually ends up having
repercussions for the character that
we'll see as we head off into the future
episodes and that's a little in-joke
from a peeps who read the book and they
come in to see a big symbol of the faith
of the seven which is shot to dwarf them
in one of its tiny markings we get a
follow-up of this in the next scene and
see that it hangs above the council
looking over every decision you might
also notice that Alison is wearing a
faith of the seven necklace throughout
most of the episode this is the most
dominant religion in Westeros and it was
brought to the Seven Kingdoms by the
Andals thousands of years before the
series takes place it tends to dominate
the Southlands of Westeros with a region
being dedicated to the quote unquote New
Gods however up north the people tend to
worship the old gods of the forest and
those in driftmark will look to the
Marlin King however this religion has a
great foothold in the realm and the fact
that Alison is now deeply involved with
his shows how she could be weaponizing
the church she could be doing this for
genuine reasons though as she of course
prayed alongside rhaenyra all the way
back in episode 2. eventually the church
did start to fall apart and this
happened after Cersei showed them A
Lannister Always Pays their debt it was
a shame shame what happened to them and
it's gonna be interesting to see how
they're woven into this series during
this time it's also important to bear in
mind that grand maester Melos died he
collapsed one night whilst climbing the
serpentine's steps and unfortunately he
didn't recover he did work closely with
viserys and I was wondering if they tied
him with that but unfortunately he's
never really brought up the source
material talks about how both Ranier and
Alison try to appoint her on May stairs
and they were basically trying to stuff
the Council of people that would end up
working in their favor however it was
the citadela always decided this and
they appointed archmaster Orwell who we
see in this episode Lord bees Brie also
gets bees belittled thank you for that
exhaustive accounting Lord beesbury I
remind you now this likely sets up
what's gonna happen with him next week
which involves some silence saying that
I won't spoil too much at this point we
visit viserys to see him rotting away
alone whilst the realm runs on without
him I think his mind has been on the
decline too and this is why he called
Alice and Emma last week before he went
to bed
go to redempt
this plays into the end with his
incoherent ramblings being
misinterpreted by the queen as he lays
on his deathbed guy is in a sorry State
and this scene struck a chord with me
quite a lot but a couple of people in my
life that have visited on their deathbed
and they came across like this it
brought back a lot of painful memories
that I think give this scene a lot of
impact for me now Damon isn't really
there to comfort him and instead he
wants the saris offend by the king
however raniera interrupts this because
she's seemingly only one that still
cares about this the new kids are
brought in but they start crying and at
this point viserys asks for his drink
which we later learn as milk of the
poppy if you cast your mind back to the
ending of episode 6 then you might
remember that lane or brought up how
renira suspected that Alison might
poison his tea if they were to leave
Damon actually ends up sniffing the cup
too clearly suspicious that this
contains something that's slowly killing
him now in the book there are two trains
of thought on how visaras passed away
without even being potential Foul Play
involved we often have to dive into
these when discussing the source
material because there's so so many
accounts over what really happened there
are some that say that he passed away in
his sleep or as others say that Alison
poisoned him whether the series keeps
things more straightforward with it
being revealed that he genuinely did die
of natural causes the series is pinned
this on the leprosy that's slowly been
developing whereas in the Burkey
suffered from several fevers and
shortness of breath now from here we
could to what our thinks the darkest
scene in the episode with one of the
servants who's been all weirded by aegon
obviously it's a really sensitive
subject and YouTube tend to restrict
videos that talk about this but it just
goes to show the monster that Alison
wants on the throne she clearly doesn't
care about what's best for the realm and
just wants to make sure her children are
in charge she seemingly Comforts the
girl and says that she believes her but
in reality she's manipulating her and is
staying silent we had some talk in the
Kevin spoiler's office about how she
might be poisoning her but I think it's
more straightforward than that with this
being likely the plan T that ranero was
given earlier in the season the books go
in depth on aegon during this time and
though we don't see them in the episode
so at this point in the original story
aegon and his sister Helena had had
twins and an older child at male or
Helena does come in and say this have
you seen Diana she supposed to dress the
children so I do think they're out there
we just don't meet them this happened
when Helena was 14 and they were called
jeheris and johera with aegon constantly
bragging about how he'd had two Heirs of
his own it's sad that the children had a
lot of things off with them though and
this is likely due the constant
inbreeding that exists within the
targaryens now we have talked about this
before in relation to the German royal
family who ended up having something
known as the Habsburg jaw after
generations of incest it caused it to
protrude more and more and more and they
ended up looking like Jimmy Hill with
Rick James's haircut now jihara didn't
cry smile or do anything that babies
typically did Andrew Harris was born
with six fingers and toes the book says
a wife and children did little to curb
the carnal appetites of Prince egg on
the Elder if mushroom is to be believed
he fathered two bastard children the
same year as the twins a boy and a girl
who's Maiden heady won at an auction on
the street of silk and a girl by one of
his mother's maidservants the tea might
not even work properly and potentially
the child could come into play Down the
Line either way aegon doesn't think he's
done anything wrong but he also clearly
isn't interested in leading I do wonder
if they're going to do the compromising
situation that they find him in next
week but his Lust For Women is something
that's constantly brought up in the
source material Katarina and Damon and I
love the design of her dress she has a
passion for fashion and I think the way
the red and black are infused together
almost with a dragon tail at the top
looks really good we also catch her
staring at the cut on her wrist and see
that it's now turned into a scar Damon
brings up the king's wisdom and how
though they say they're leading with
that he's clearly completely incoherent
Alison's ignorance over this speaks to
why she doesn't question his final words
and we learn that the kingdom has also
had all its Targaryen iconography
stripped out so that the faith of the
seven can be put in its place she's
drank the Kool-Aid and now believes that
a higher power is guiding her so even if
she has to do things she can lay the
blame elsewhere go to the Courtyard to
see the strongs returning in a scene
that Echoes the one that appeared in
episode 6. they're both getting stabbed
at us and look I know why people with
dreadlocks can be a bit you know but hey
maybe you guys could no no never mind
anyway in the court we catches Eamon and
Kristen Cole battle it out in an intense
sparring match with the former getting
the upper hand the book says that
despite the loss of his eye that he
became a proficient swordsman solely
because of Kristen and man is about to
become the most badass character in the
show it also notes that he's unforgiving
and this ties into The Grudge that he
still Bears over the loss of his eye now
I said this in our trailer breakdown but
Eamonn is in full gangster mode right
now looking like a cross between liquid
snake and big boss Jason Luke are
clearly out of their depth and it really
hammers home how much of an asset Alison
that Eamon is now character that we
dealt me in this episode is his son
Darren this was another one of Alison's
children who was born during this time
and he was supposed to be 12 by the year
126 AC the Burke says he was the most
popular of the Queen's son due to being
clever in courteous however sadly we
don't get him them here now the reason
he might not show up in the series is
probably one of two things firstly we
have way too many characters at this
point to keep introducing every week and
therefore they probably just wanted to
keep things simple he was also sent to
Old Town when he was a child and he
served as a cup Bearer to Lord Hightower
for several years so that gives them a
reason to not include the character now
at this point Raymond is brought in and
in another detail that shows the high
Towers have taken over we can see the
knights are wearing their symbol on
their chess piece the beacon at the top
is burning with a green flame again
tying back to how they've declared war
he goes to Alison and Otto in order to
make a deal and over at the weirwood
tree we see renera doing the same thing
rhaenys of course inspired her name and
she married her son in order to keep up
appearances however she knows it was all
a charade and that the kids aren't true
valerians raniera plays to this need to
have her grandchildren on the throne and
offers a betrothal and hey you to be
fair you could do with some extra blood
because the gene pool is looking pretty
shallow in the and she allows it to
happen and it offers a win for an era
who secures driftmark to her side that
night renera goes to her father's bed
and he mistakes her for someone else
oreshadowing the mistaken identity at
the end she brings up the song of ice
and fire which further plans the idea in
his head that he has to talk about it in
the final scene occur to the morning
with a strong focus on the model that's
now covered in cobwebs which carries a
lot of symbolism in a scene that mirrors
the one from episode 1 we see viserys's
wounds are now being tended to but that
they now run over his entire body the
effect work they do here is incredible
and we see him as a withered old Mr
Burns man who has to be heavily sedated
so he doesn't succumb to his pain the
faith of the seven sigil also shines
down on him and Otto is told to arrange
a suburb for the family in the throne
room the claims are considered and I'm
pretty sure in the book that vaman did
the bastard speech back at drift Mark
away from the court the way it reads in
the text is that they heard about the
comments made by him and then Damon was
dispatched there as mentioned earlier
the book hasn't being fed to Cyrax and
then his cousins went to the kingdom
where they had their tongues removed
here though his body has returned to
drift Mark after it's prepared by the
silent sisters these are members of the
faith of the seven and their job is to
dress bodies for funerals as we've seen
in the series every house has their own
way of doing things the targaryens burn
the bodies whereas the valerians send
them out to sea either way it's way more
impeccable seeing how it plays out here
and Damon even drops a very
tongue-in-cheek pun after making the guy
look like Terence and Billy viserys
returns to the throne to see the claim
himself and upon this happening Otto
immediately steps out of it he clearly
said in it believing that he could take
control of this hearing but viserys
battles his way to the chair in order to
deliver judgment it's a highly impactful
scene that's one of his last Deeds to
ensure his daughter's safety it of
course mirrors the entrance made by
Alison at the wedding and in the end
he's held up by his brother Damon who
previously pushed him away a tear a
little tear might have rolled down my
face and what a brilliant way to show us
the Return of the King when he spacks up
the claim and I tell you what I loved
seeing the look on Otto and Alison's
face [ __ ] you [ __ ] off no egg on smirks
and again this is because he's reluctant
to be forced into a position of
leadership baymen can't take the
decision though summer man's gotta
become a Pez dispenser can't show this
as I don't want to get demonetized and
hey are probably also can't show
viserys's missing eye so bear that in
mind for later in the breakdown also I
was gonna do a viz Vision pun but I'll
skip that now my man viz kinda wishes
he'd not bothered going back there and I
may I tell you just just let the guy
play with his train set just please one
day just give me a flashback series
that's just for saris having a good time
now that night they have a serp app and
this is described in great detail in the
book in the book this was all basically
a show put on to impress the king and in
the work they wear their opposite houses
colors in a show of good faith for
example runyera wore green whilst
Allison Don the classic red and black it
this is something she also wore back
when Damon returned to King's Landing
but since then her dresses have gone on
a color Journey episode 1 had a wearing
a very light blue dress which of the
episodes slowly changed in the dark
green like how it is now the story says
that Declarations of Love were made and
both Otto and Damon even salute each
other the former said the prince was
very courageous whilst Damon thanked him
for his legal service as the hand of the
king it said that viserys was really
happy with this and that he went to bed
smiling however after this it ended up
looking like an episode of Jerry
Springer with her family all falling out
the book has this event recounted by
mushroom who says that Eamonn one eye
rose up to toast his nephews and he said
I've never known someone so strong as my
sweet nephews bit bit out of line that
but it might be being genuine and and
this was Then followed up by his speech
saying so let us drain our cups to these
three strong boys josaris was also said
to have asked Helena for her dance and
both of these events end up happening in
the episode the entire thing here is
meant to be a celebration of the houses
being brought together I've just
realized I haven't asked you to unite
our houses by subscribing to the channel
if you enjoyed the video then please do
and don't forget to hit the Thumbs Up
Button cheers now viserys tries to unite
the family's one final time and it
actually goes down well with Allison and
raniera who realize they have more
Uncommon than they don't however they've
poisoned their kids to the point there's
no coming back Elena also says something
here that I can't quite make out
as I'm sure many of you know we get sent
these episodes early by HBO but
unfortunately we don't get closed
captions for them so I can't quite
understand this line let me know below
and as we've discussed in other videos
this could be hinting to one of their
Fates he did talk about aiming closing
an eye to get a dragon and also
predicted the marriage of Damon and
runira in the last entry sounds like
beasts beneath the borders but yeah let
me know below exactly what it is because
you'll know by now now aegon's aegon is
brought down by Helena and then Jace
asking her to dance takes things too far
especially because it's one of those
weird hop dances it's just a jump to the
left
thank you
now it looks like everything's gonna be
okay though and similar The Source
material viserys goes back to bed
thinking it's all coming up Milhouse
Luke ends up causing Eamon to rise after
laughing at him and this strong speech
all kicks off really shows how clever
George Armon was by making the surname
something he can use as a compliment but
here it's belittling others and it shows
the balls that Eamonn has he has a stare
off against Daemon and I love the way
that they're laying the seeds between
these two for what's coming down the
line similar to Raymond Eamonn sounds
similar to Damon and both are the
brothers of people that others hold up
as their King Bruno says she's going
back to Dragonstone and that she'll
return but we'll talk later on about
what happens in this case that night we
see mazaria hearing something from an
informant in the castle and how this
will play out I'm not even sure it could
however be playing into the characters
of blood and cheese who might be brought
up next week and I'm sure if you read
the book you'll be familiar with who
they are it might be about the maid and
potentially one of aegon's kids but yeah
let me know below what you think
curtiserus on his deathbed and in his
ramblings he talks about the prince he
was promised renera asked him earlier in
the episode if he believed it was true
and here he answers by saying that he
does however due to the name of the
prophecy being aegon Allison
misinterprets this as him saying that
their son should rule the prince who has
promised prophecy was of course passed
on from King to King and King to Queen
and thus Alison would never have been
told this so we can see how things can
be lost like this and misinterpreted
down the line he says you are the one
and Jon Snow did come from anira's
bloodline tying back into this we've
already dropped a full breakdown on how
last episode actually makes this all
make sense and how the blood and the
blade carries an extra symbolic meaning
to it Alison however thinks it's
viserys's Last Wish to make egg on the
rightful air and this will set up why
she wants to fight for him on the throne
we get this reaching out almost like
someone is above him and he does this as
his final words
now the series plays things slightly
differently to the book in that Helena
brought her kids up to viz who explain
the story of how they got their names he
let one play with his pearl ring and
talking about how King joharis rode with
his dragon to the wall in order to
defeat Invaders the work says though the
children had heard the story a dozen
times before they listened attentively
afterwards the king sent them away
leading his weariness and a tightness in
his chest then viserys House of
Targaryen the first of his name King of
the Andals the Rhino and the first men
lord of the Seven Kingdoms and protector
of the realm closed his eyes and went to
sleep he never woke he was 52 years old
and had rained over most of Westeros for
26 years the chapter then ends with the
ominous line then the storm broke and
the dragons danced now that concludes
the episode and it was another another
bloody Banger I'm absolutely in love
with this series and for me it gets
better every week I really bring the
book to life and do way more with it
than I'd ever even expected next week is
going to kick off too and for the next
part of the video we're gonna get into
the spoilers if you don't want to know
then thanks for sticking through the
video and please hit the thumbs up on
your way out now viserys's body is
discovered by his servant who quickly
tells the queen but rather than
reporting it to the rest of the realm
she rushes to the council to secure
aegon will be the king they refuse to
tell renera and she goes into labor
eventually she learns that they've made
egg on the king whilst this is going on
and it causes a lot of stress but birth
is an arduous process and an extremely
painful one in which the child is
stillborn it apparently has a dragon's
tail and renira blames Alison for not
only killing her child but also for
taking the throne she even calls the
baby a monster at one point which we
might see in the episode it all kicks
off in the realm with some staying loyal
toranera including Lord beesberry we
don't know what happens with him as some
account say he's locked in a dungeon
whilst others say that he's murdered on
the spot all gonna kick off and I hope
to see you back for it next week
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you let me know in the
comments below we are in a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of dollar and thunder on the 15th of
October and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want to be
notes to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of rings of power
which will be linked on screen right now
you can know the entire thing and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more about that show now
without the way thanks for singing
through the video I've been Paul and I
see you next time take care peace